your friend is a Duchess of Sussex it's
so funny because she's still Megan to me
for the first time ever
Megan Merkel's close friends are
speaking out in a sneak peek at the
upcoming CBS News special Megan and
Harry plus one the Duchess of Sussex is
besties offer rare intimate insight into
the couple's life as they embrace their
new roles as mom and dad to their
newborn son Archie who has already made
history as the first British American
biracial baby born into the royal family
their child is going to represent what
the world is now this is a dawn of a new
generation I don't know it's just
relevant
that's Daniel Martin Megan's longtime
friend and makeup artist who gets
emotional talking about the negative
headlines his friend has faced since
marrying Harry in May 2018 sorry what
are the tears about for you I think
because I know her so well she doesn't
deserve this negative press et caught up
with CBS this morning co-host Gayle King
in New York on Wednesday and she dished
on what she learned from meeting Megan's
friends we all knew that but they have a
new baby coming in the first year and I
think everybody loves a good love story
you know Megan's had some knocks in the
media in the UK that's certainly not the
case here so we're gonna hear from her
friends who know her well who were at
her wedding they are not trying to
defend her but they just want people to
know there's a whole different side to
her that people don't know but at the
end of the day these two are very United
and very strong and the baby just sort
of adds to all of that and while she did
get a good look at what the royal couple
is really like she didn't get any intel
on the origin of baby Archie's name I
love that name it's so unexpected people
thought Albert Arthur James Philip
Spencer
I love the fact is Archie to me is
friendly but it also feels very
substantial too I think it's great all
of it